what about
close kind of competitors i don't know
if you would put it that way but if you
look in the space of ideas
uh competitor cryptocurrencies like
polka dot
yeah what is some interesting difference
between cordano and polkadot
technically philosophically historically
is that something you think about when
you think about the future of cardano
yeah i bet we do we actually have a
whole group of people that do business
intelligence and comparative analysis
and
we're getting to a point where we want
to start eventually forking their code
and running private versions of it just
playing around with things
getting fascinating better interesting
consensus actually does this they
actually did it with eos and they wrote
this lovely report like trashing eos
saying hey by the way all those claims
these guys made are
just not true but you know it's nice to
do that it's nice to use your
competitors technology or
you know competing protocol technology
because you learn a lot along the
process it's not all bad
you know there's always something there
because they have different trade-offs
and customers that potentially are more
interesting
like right now we're rocking how do we
want to do the side chain model of
cardano
polka dots actually a tremendously
useful piece of infrastructure for that
conversation
because they copied part of our
infrastructure you know
gavin's a trained computer scientist he
got his phd from
uh york and he read our papers obviously
and
he realized that oro boris was a really
good starting place for
building a proof-of-stake system so
polka dots consensus is very similar to
ours
and so if you're saying hey how do you
do a good side chain model
with proof an order style proof of stake
well we already have
this parachain thing right and so so now
by just looking at that
i can kind of get an idea of how one way
of doing it
and so that's just beautiful that we
live in a space where that's there it's
open source and it's really good you
just
say okay well we'll just take that and
adopt that there's no shame you know
um the other side of it is that polka
dot
really has focused a lot on commercial
adoption silicon valley adoption and
getting
real use and utility i say in a much
more sustainable way than ethereum is
focused on
ethereum was kind of a spray and prey
thing polkadot was more of like hey
let's let's go ahead and actually curate
our ecosystem more carefully
and we're going to build it in a way
where there's predictable
or as predictable cost as possible with
the rollout of the infrastructure
and you know that that's so important
for a business
it's not necessarily important for an
experiment or a startup
where you know they're just trying to
get populations quickly as possible
we'll figure out later but if you're
actually sitting here saying i
need to know what my expenses are three
years five years ten years into the
future
you need predictability there i think
they have a better shot of it than
anything in
f2 or or with currently ethereum
now there the big contrast between the
two systems those
we actually have native multi-asset we
have a different accounting model i
think our base ledger is far more
expressive
our rate of evolution with proof of
stake is much faster than theirs because
they're based on derivative work and
we already have orover's omega and other
things there i think we have a better
ultimately a better side chain model
will come because we have something
called mithril for that
but we learned a lot from their work the
other thing is that we thought about
governance a lot more carefully
in my view and we have catalyst and
voltaire and really the key there is
saying
how do we make sure that every single
person who holds data can
participate in the network that wasn't a
high design priority
of polkadot it was more fast commercial
adoption the acquisition of customers
will come to governance later
and those were just different business
philosophies
but it's nice to have a competitor like
that and oftentimes i've said that
polkadot's like ethereum 1.5 it's what
f2 probably should have been
there was what vitalik wanted to do
which was incredibly aggressive
and brilliant but it's a lot and there's
so much execution risk in that plan and
i think they've had like six years of
playing around with it had they gone
down the polka dot road
they probably would have been a market
with it in 2018 and because they already
had the network effect
they would have had years of building on
that iterating that and they already had
a path to it too all they had to do was
just give elaine she and her
cohorts at cornell you know five ten
million dollar grant snow white would
have been uh the dominant protocol not
orborus
in the proof of stake space so it's
really fascinating historically when you
look at these things the rivalries and
what they did and what they didn't do
and you know gavin had a chance to have
c-plus plus ethereum be used as the uh
as
ibm's enterprise blockchain the only
reason they didn't do it is
you know it was licensed gpl and i think
they wanted to re-license apache
if you ever talked to bob summerwall he
was there at the time and he had this
amazing story about
like these terrible fights where you
know he's like guys just re-license the
goddamn code let's figure out a way to
make this happen
so that we can you know get this huge
network effect of of being
basically ibm's play they didn't do it
they created fabric
you know these types of things uh so
there's uh there's a lot of lore
and stories in that respect but the
space is better because of
polka dot and there's a lot of good
people there web 3
is a good concept and you know we run
into their people in germany and zurich
a lot
and they've always been cordial and
friendly and really affable
you